so so um good morning everyone welcome
to the dtps seminar before we introduce
our invited speaker today let's go over
some rules as usual
first of all please mute yourself during
the talk if you have immediate questions
you are welcome to a mute and ask
or otherwise please use the chat room to
post your questions so that will address
your questions at the end
um in the Q a session
second today's seminar is open to
external audience so no classified
discussion is allowed finally the talk
will be record and upload to our YouTube
channel now let me introduce our speaker
it is an honor to your host Matthias
Chung who goes by Tia Tia is currently
an associate professor in the Department
of Mathematics at Emory University since
before that he held faculty positions at
Virginia Tech and Texas State University
and he was a postdoctoral fellow at
Emory University
he obtained his doctoral degree from the
University of Lubeck and master degree
from the University of Hamburg both in
Germany
Tia is a Humboldt fellow and an active
member of Siam
the focus of TS research is on solving
ill post and large-scale invest problems
with applications in different
disciplines such as image processing
dynamical systems he develops and
analyzed efficient numerical methods
with regularization randomized methods
patient immersion and scientific machine
learning
to date here we present his work on back
data inverse problems promoting sparsity
and learning to recognize
please enjoy the wonderful talk now
without further Ado let me hand it to
Tia by asking one random question so
besides Atlanta and stefana what is your
favorite city in Georgia
in Georgia uh Savannah
mm-hmm so then or did you exclude
Savannah yeah maybe excluding Savannah
also yeah okay so maybe Athens I need to
go then to um Georgia State you know uh
University of Georgia which is a nice
town over there yeah I heard that also
okay yeah uh yeah the stage is all yours
right now okay thanks so much for having
me Tony and uh for introducing for the
introduction I'm very excited to talk
about some of my research uh with unan
uh fear that can be also a discussion
about about some new directions and I'm
very happy if you interrupt me if you
have any questions or comments uh
throughout the talk so I would be happy
about that so uh let me start here let's
see oh yeah there we go uh I wanted to
start with uh a little bit more of my
introduction so first of all here in the
front you you see uh Emery University
and then the background you see the
skyline from Atlanta so that is a pretty
city as well and uh I'm sitting right in
this building here with the observatory
over here somewhere at the side and of
course it's not fall right now but very
green uh light green at the moment so
um Emory University is nicely located
close to Atlanta or in Atlanta and uh
yeah it's always nice to visit that
place
all right um
as Tony already said so my my work is
somewhere in the field of inverse
problems
scientific machine learning uq Dynamic
assistance all involved and I just made
it a little bit schematic over here so
in in the intersection of of these
methods nevertheless Central to all what
I'm doing uh two major things and that
is a model and data and with that I
think I fit somehow within the theme of
the seminar which is data driven
physical simulations
so what I'm particularly interested in
is
um inverse problems so here I did a very
simple sketch of what our daily
derivative or what I assume what is data
model driven if I have just data given
my model model less information could be
just a line and I cannot extrapolate
information out of this regime where my
data giving me good information
on the other hand if I would have just a
model the model lines could go lie
everywhere where I don't have any proper
information however both together might
give me good predictions for future
events or for
um things we haven't observed
so this is a big regime and today
um I want to talk specifically about
inverse problem and how how better to uh
illustrate this with some images and I
give here just a simple image de
blurring example this one here let's
assume that is our true image and let's
assume we have some blur in there and we
assume this is done by some forward
operation maybe some kernel some
gaussian kernel and we get a blurred
image and the actually interest is
coming from a blurred and noisy image to
go back to the True Image so we can
write this down as a linear problem and
we have done that many many times before
going the opposite direction is
essentially just inverting the operator
and we should get back our image if we
were to do that here in this example
that leads to a total failure of
recovering the information we actually
want although I have the true model in
there so what happens so the part of
inverse problems is that it is ill pose
meaning noise in the data or in the
model or in the numerics even though can
be Amplified so and that is summarized
by by the notion of imposedness or a
conditioned of an operator and we say a
problem is opposed if a solution doesn't
exist is not unique or does not depend
continuously
on the data and that goes back to hadama
we are seeing here on the very right
all right that that is small the the
stage of inverse problems and
Illustrated with some some images
um we can write this in many different
forms and I don't want to take the the
Bayesian approach I will here just look
at the variational approach we typically
have a data uh Fidelity term a loss
function between yeah the model and the
data and to stabilize uh the the data
fit we need some prior knowledge which
is encoded and typically some
regularization and this regularization
might depend even some of some hyper
parameters which are imposed
regularization parameters or in your in
your gaussian or if you have other
distributions where your regularizer
comes from
some other terms which might influence
um your prior knowledge which you want
to induce into your system so as we have
seen earlier just looking at the yeah
the data Fidelity Trend might lead to an
Impulse problem and we need the
stabilization
this standard example here is a taken
off problem where we have a data
Fidelity term over here with some
regularization term where we want the
solution to be close yeah somehow in
some sense to zero yeah that is the
standard setup
and of course we are doing this for many
many many years but how where are still
the challenges and one thing uh is
definitely the dimensionalities if we
think about uh yeah training a new
network as an inverse problem is
definitely the dimensionality involved
in that or if we have reconstructions of
some medical MRI images which are four
four dimensional then this uh problem
goes fast out of hand and standard
methods do not necessarily apply
another thing which I already uh
talked a little bit about is the
regularization it's uh how do I include
this for example how do I pick a
regularization parameter this is a
priority not necessarily known it is
sometimes derived from the noise uh
um distribution of our problem but that
is not necessarily uh there and the last
thing is probably the uncertainty
quantification if we want for
large-scale problems also to know a
little bit about how certain we are
about our inverse solution then this one
is typically computational very
expensive and this is a challenge to
work on that
all right I will mostly talk about the
first two parts and for now at least
more a little bit the uncertainty
quantification but although it is a
topic on its own
all right more specifically I will talk
about
a new project a new method we developed
and this is what we call variable
projected document lagrangian and I will
get into a lot of details over there the
archive paper you can find over here
um we're lucky to get some funding and I
want to acknowledge NSF there and this
is a joint project with Rosie Renault
and Pedro strenues
all right let's dive into that and look
at the following I want to solve the
following uh yeah inverse problems here
I have a data Fidelity term and you see
I I for Simplicity I'm looking at a
linear problem and some regularization
term and you saw taking off
regularization has a two non-square here
we look at a one Norm
and some Matrix D over here as well
which is some operator which
we want to project our solution onto and
typically what we want is sparsity in
our solution and L1 uh a zero type Norm
is not suitable or computational too
expensive we use uh the one Norm over
here which promotes sparsity in general
is the rip condition is satisfied and so
on nevertheless we have done that many
times and this is typically refer to as
a generalized loss of problem the
generalized comes through an operator d
a otherwise we just called it a lasso
problem
all right and some regularization
parameter over here
all right so to give you an example
where where these type of problems come
up and this is definitely a single uh uh
signal processing more specifically
signal compression where the signal
needs to compress and you want a lot of
pieces to be zero compressed sensing and
you already see these are all topics
which came up especially in the late
2000s and 2000 started 2000s
um dictionary learning is something else
but also denoising image de blurring and
other things I will talk about a couple
of potential applications it's a wide
variety
which we can look at
so this
generalized lasso is computationally
expensive since we need iterative
methods to solve these things we cannot
directly solve it like the taken off
problems if we have not you know not too
large problem and we can just invert but
here we typically need a iterative
method and it is a computer internally
more challenging than for example
uh then the point I already made also
here we typically don't know the
regularization parameter how can we
determine this parameter especially in
the sentence or in the settings of L1
regularization which is not standard
many tools have been developed for the
L2 Norm for the tick enough problem for
the L1 it is a little bit harder
of course uh there is a zoo of methods
out there to attack this um generalized
lasso problem and I stated a couple of
uh methods over here and if you want to
I actually put one more animal into into
the zoo but I want to convince you that
uh there there is a good reason and to
use these kind of methods all right to
start with I I just want to to be on the
same page that everyone can hopefully
follow I want to introduce ADM and
derive it and just see how we developed
the variable projected augmented
approach
all right
let's keep going so this was our problem
over here and uh we can reformal editors
by introducing just a surrogate uh
variable here the Y and uh what we do is
we are just enforcing the Y to be equal
to DX we are just replacing this piece
in general that might be a bad idea
everyone who has some optimization will
say Okay a constrained optimization
problem is significantly harder than an
unconstrained optimization problem why
would we do that we will get to that
so the first thing you do is okay I have
this constraint problem I form a lot the
LaGrange function and include also a
penalty term and this is a quadratic
penalty term where we call this the
augmented lagration here I have my
LaGrange multipliers over here and this
is is my augmented the branching where I
not enforce it strictly but have some
penalty term when Y is not equal to DX
and um
you see that the last two terms are some
quadratic terms and we can reshuffle
these both and just reformulate this
both together to have it in this form
which is easier to uh to handle and then
the C takes the form of all LaGrange
multiplier with uh some some Factor over
here of course the Lambda over here is
an additional penalty parameter which
penalizes uh our non-conformity to our
constraint
all right this is augmented
and before I start talking about admm
again I want to scale that and say let's
look at the generic function and for
Simplicity let let F be strictly convex
and I want to assume it's separable
meaning I have two sets of variables
which uh have different meanings or
which I can separate you can think about
if you are familiar with a lot of
training neural networks each layer has
a set of
parameters and they have different
meanings they are interacting
but they have different meanings or
might live on different scales right or
you made I have some linear parameters
and some nonlinear branch
uh how can you solve these kind of
generic uh problems so actually what we
have seen is we just uh
um artificially introduced variable in
our previous slide so this one can come
through uh and yeah reformulation of a
separate into a separable problem or
naturally appearing in applications and
one example is super resolution
where you have a lot of small images and
you want to reconstruct a larger image
with sub pixel information
let me tell you what we could do so the
first approach is just ignore that we
have two different variables right and
just combine them both together and take
your favorite method to use an iterative
optimization method maybe there's a some
gradient descent method or
some some
bfgs or whatever optimization method you
want over here and you want to minimize
that let me go back sorry for that and
this is one approach that oftentimes
suffers some slow convergence especially
if the para the variables are on
different scales or uh have diff very
different meaning
to uh combat this there are typically
two approaches which you can use one is
called in The Descent
what you're doing there is you are
taking your favorite optimization method
again going in One Direction a step and
then in the other direction step and you
are continuing this process over and
over again
and there's a third approach which is
called alternating Direction
and the alternating Direction instead of
going a step in a direction you're
optimizing in this direction and then
you optimize in the opposite direction
and you uh continue this approach over
and over again
so and I think with this last
illustration over here we we are very
close to our admm method alternating
direction we had two variables uh in
here and we are alternating essentially
over this verbs so
that is ADM essential essentially you
have an update on your parameter X
minimizing this uh problem over here
then you update your y minimizing this
problem and the LaGrange multiplier and
I don't want to say too much that you
can update them as well
instead of increasing the penalty
parameter you can use this application
so now let's
digest this a little bit and what what
just happened
so first of all we have here suddenly a
linearly squares problem since our Y is
constant
this one is now easy to solve right we
know we can solve a linearly squares
problem since Y is constant this is
perfect wonderful to do
the second thing is
this guy over here if you look at the Y
it goes in here and here and it is not
convoluted by a matrix means all these
optimization problems are independent
first of all
and it is the so-called shrinkage
problem so we can actually have an
analytic solution for that by this
computer uh comp it's not complicated
but but an easy update for me okay
details we don't need to know about this
right but this is a fairly
straightforward than to do
and then the last part is the legal
update on the LaGrange multiplies
so if we look at this method where is
the computational most effort we need to
put in that is of course the first part
over here there I have some uh yeah
matrices A and D and I need to solve
this linear uh problem so if I take a
standard method it will be somehow of
the complexity of some however many
iterations I took in my auto iteration
times the dimension LA Times N squared
some somewhere around this
but of course things line four is the
most expensive one
we typically uh do an iterative method
to to solve this and we don't even
potentially accurately solve that maybe
go just a couple of iterations right
um another way is to do pre the the
pre-comp uh decomposition of these
matrices beforehand because you're
always applying the same Matrix so you
can could do something like a hlsp
factorization if you uh consider the
normal equations right something like
that
all right
so uh so far so good uh that is admm but
I didn't tell you that there is actually
a fourth option of what we discussed
earlier and the first option is the
variable projection
before we did optimization optimization
or updates that updates that or ignoring
but you can also hibernate this
update in One Direction
and optimize in the other one
and this is what we call variable
projection and we can actually write it
in this form like I showed over here an
update just of X and somehow eliminate
the second variable within the first
okay so this one was actually developed
uh in the early 70s uh by Gala pillera
and that was particularly for uh the
separable non-linear uh problems where
you have a of X where X is a non-linear
operator or non-linear parameter
determining your operator and Y is a
linear variable
so for this it has been developed and we
could easily apply this also for uh for
the generalized lasso approach so all we
need to do is changing line four where
we do an update on the linear uh problem
and then solve for the second one
I want to just to emphasize over here
that we do it actually opposite to what
what uh what the the variable projection
was intended to and that is uh um
updating the linear and optimizing over
the non-linear because the non-year is
actually straightforward
so uh this is what we call the variable
projected augmented background statement
and if you look at uh this um did I have
it over here um I think I might might
have put it in the next slide
this is a projected problem over here
and several nice things happen to uh to
this update it is if I uh compute
gradient information the nonlinear
problem goes away because we have
optimality so a lot of computational
pieces will get easier
um here you could for example stake as
the step Direction uh the negative
gradient right that that would be one
option but there are other choices right
and this is just one one of
um I also could compute a line search
parameter actually I could for
Simplicity here just use the linearized
line search parameter the optimal
linearized line search parameter and
then it would be something like a
conjugate gradient just one conjugate
gradient step in my linear problem
and the computational cost if I'm
looking at this algorithm it just
reduces here from N squared to n that is
uh what the difference is and since we
are now in the realm of standard
optimization method I could use any
optimization method to use for my uh for
my um yeah search Direction
and standard stopping criteria as you
can impose on on this in constraint
optimization
all right so I think it is good time to
First Look look at an example how how
this works let's let's let's let's see
that or I just summarized everything
again over here with a particular choice
this is just a simple choice I can think
of to to make it uh
um work the nice thing is about there uh
just Matrix Vector multiplies there's no
inversion in there in the algorithm it
is very straightforward so there's no
lsqr which I need to pack in there like
with admm and so on this uh will just
need per iteration to metric Specter
multiplies with A and B and one
transverse so one adjoint for that for
each
all right
um before I show the numerics just uh
just a quick and I put a couple of
things under the rock but we can show
that uh if we use the variable projected
implemented lagration uh method then we
can show that the method will converge
there's uniqueness uh we need to show
uniqueness of the projected problem and
then we need to show that the variable
projection method converges and then
later on that augmented lagrangian
method converges and we are coupling all
of these elements together then into one
all right so now now we have time for
some numerical experiments let's let's
start with a couple of things first of
all uh this is a denoising problem the
symbols what we can think of so the app
operator a is just identity and the D
operator here comes from a total
variation meaning what I actually want
in the derivative derivative in each
Direction I want just a few jumps right
and that is what the D operator does
over here so it's a 2d
total variation
we are comparing to ADM and there we use
lsqr for the inner solve and here for
just uh illustration we pick a
regularization parameter 10 and a
standard stopping criteria I think here
10 to the minus 4. and let's see how
both of these methods perform
so here on the left you see the
iteration count and the residual over
here in the log 10 and here is the arrow
over here so what you will see is that
the residual and also the errors go
nearly to The Identical values the
relative arrows are nearly identical
but what you see is admm uses less
iterations than Wii U
however this is an arbitrary count right
because what does iterations really mean
so we want to look at what is the actual
work we are doing so we are looking at
the wall clock time
and there the picture looks very
different
if we look on the left we are looking at
sizes of this image and just increases
sizes and we also compare to a tick
enough solution of course takenovo is
just a linear Inver uh inversion and the
time is very uh fast however the
Reconstruction will be terrible uh
because that is not we won't don't want
an L2
regularizer over here and if you look at
the wall clock time the blue one the V
power variable projection method is
significantly faster despite they both
produce essentially in the same image
the curves of the relative Arrow lie on
the same path over here and if we look
at the timings over here how admm versus
repo looks like it is yeah between yeah
seven and nine speed up and I also
looked at the number of uh um yeah
Matrix Vector multiplications which I
needed within admm or vpa
that I was already encouraging let me
show you another image over here that
came from the beginning
um the girl was a tall earring over here
and what I just did I
um did
um an impacting example and there's
essentially an indicator function which
we have over here and what I did as a
small test
uh is what happens when I change my
regularization parameter uh too much
timing and to my relative error and you
see if I take a small regularization
error then then my timing is very bad
and if I take it too high it will be bad
as well but when I hit around about a
good reconstruction that method is
fairly fast
so that shows the importance of a
regularization problem
but how do I select this one
and there are many different methods
already out there as I mentioned
discrepancy principle or upre and
generalized cross validation they are
all methods which we can utilize however
they get a little computational
expensive
and they don't generalize to the L1 so
easily more needs to be put in there
but we took a different approach we said
we want to learn the regularization
so what we assume is there is a mapping
from our observation to our
regularization parameter and I put this
bold face here since we think about this
not only as a regularization parameter
some hyper parameters or some
information about your prior
you can construct a neural network which
you parameterize to approximate this
mapping and you learn this map and here
I just for completeness I just wrote
down a neural network but I think I
don't need to In This Crowd go through
many details there you you know what the
neural network is you're mapping from B
to the regularization and it's
parameterized with all the weights and
bias terms and you want to learn on the
parameters in this network to get a good
mapping from B to the regularization
part that means once I've learned this
and you be I'm getting I just need to uh
forward propagate through my network and
get a regularization
um just some details on the how we put
uh pick the loss function and so on and
let me uh just uh summarize what we do
the learning is the offline phase we
generate some training data some B and
some Optima regularization permit we can
do that since we are in the training
phase and we know the underlying truth
over there
then we set up then you're on the
network and learn the neural network uh
from this data in the offline phase we
get a new B propagate forward and then
we can compute the inverse problem
so notice here I don't want to throw
away the physical model right I'm
learning just on the prior I don't learn
the mapping from B to the
reconstructions I want to still have the
physics in my system but I want to
induce information on my prior
all right here is a simple example for a
heat equation one the heat equation just
uh proof of concept and TI log a look at
the tick enough problem generated a
bunch of random signals with some noise
and I even chose different noise levels
right with this I can do this or however
I want
I compared these methods to UPI GCV
these are standard methods and
discrepancy principle I cut out because
otherwise you wouldn't see anything in
the pictures that perform underperformed
significantly there's another method
which is uh on on the optimal experiment
comes from optimal experimental design
and then I use two different neural
networks one is a DNN
um and one is an lrm or extreme learning
machine which is just a linear Network
essentially
without a activation
so and we learn on some training data so
let me show you the results over here on
the left hand side
you we look at the test set and we look
at the difference between our recovered
parameter and the optimal
and I use all these different methods
this is should be an IO ID sorry for
that and of course it should be around
zero that would be optimal right so to
hit the optimal parameters and you'll
see the DNS
performs extremely well over here
compared to any of the statistical
methods or to the linearized model
if we translate this in the
Reconstruction Era over the here in the
right hand side you will see this is
optimal I can do in the black over here
and I can zoom in and you see the DNN
pretty much capture it very well right
that is good
all right so
um disadvantage of uh of standard method
is uh is that it is very expensive to
compute the regularization parameter and
it is not always optimal but you don't
need any learning process within that
why dnns and oids needs learning to
generate you regularization parameter
but the dnns perform extremely well and
are adaptive to your data once you get
new data in you get a new regularization
problem
especially for these data which I was
presented at
I I took one more example from
tomography over here which is also a
linear operation and I slowly curve back
to the generalized lasso problem
um
let me go back if you don't I'm not
familiar uh with tomography tomography
uh
um you essentially have a source and a
receiver over here and you are having
line integrals and you uh computer
alternation coefficient and you are
essentially put your data uh in one line
You observe over here and then you're
rotating and you put all the data on
here but from this we call it cyanogram
you want to reconstruct the image and
this is the chef Logan Phantom and there
are randomized chat Logan we use for to
training this data over here
the setup is as we had before with some
noise levels and I don't want to go into
the details only that we use the
regularization now which is the
generalized loss of problem where we
cannot so easily use statistical
standard statistical methods to estimate
the regularization
and here are some test images or
training images
we have over here
and let me just do quickly the DNN setup
of course this we are operating on
images so we are talking about
convolutional neural networks makes the
training easier
um
small note on that actually training
this network to the regularization
format is extremely easy you're going to
one dimension this is not large
dimensional problem right you're going
from a large dimensional to a
one-dimensional problem which is a piece
of cake for these neural networks
um okay that is all set up uh how we
learn we do use Adam and mini batches
with a certain learning rate over here
um and I look at the two different dnns
the DNN and the shallow network over
over here and you see the optimal
regularization parameter compared to the
true uh the optimal compared to the
Learned regularization parameter and if
this one is uh yeah around this line
over here would be best and you see that
DNN does pretty well the lrm cannot
learn so well because it's a linear
mapping you might get even negative
regularization parameters which in this
case is not uh of any value
okay so how how does now the uh
performance look there if I look at the
distribution of my discrepancy between
my learned one and the optimal one I see
I'm very well uh performed very well
with my DNN
um looking over here with a relative
error and the density over here the
optimal is highlighted in black and the
DNN I think we can ignore the linear the
neural network
it performs pretty well and I want to
point something out which I was
surprised about and that is
why is our neural network better than
the optimal one that cannot be
and uh I at a certain point notice that
the optimal regularization parameter are
numerically solved and in some cases it
didn't find it wasn't a local Minima and
it never found the optimal one why the
neural network was able to compensate
even for that which was very impressive
of course we we did a lot of other
experiments for example took out total
out of sample images which uh generated
still very very good results
all right I'm I'm circling back to a
couple of applications to give you some
time uh or give us some time for for
discussion this is a very exciting uh
recent work we are working on 5D MRI
cardiac Mi and if you ask me what 5D MRI
is I don't know what the 5D actually
means here uh that uh it sounds uh
strange but it comes not from me okay
the point 5D means actually it comes
through two different phases a
respiratory and the cardiac and you want
to reconstruct a 3D Volume in time with
a respiratory and the cardiac phase
and this was a project which we just
recently started and we looked at admm
which they standard used and we just
implemented vpal on a very small scale
and this is a timing uh from 14.4 hours
to 4.5 and that is just just the
simplest form we could do that is just
the starting point and if you think
about you want your results of a cardiac
image very fast 14.4 hours is not
reasonable but 4.5 goals already in this
right direction nevertheless in the
beginning I showed you a speedoff of
seven to nine we are there not there yet
so there's still something to do there's
also other two methods we can use or
under sampling where we are now uh not
yet nevertheless uh the the sizes of the
problem are extremely large and data
size is extremely large and
these methods are they are performing
pretty well on this example
um a question I often get is uh what is
where is the difference between variable
projection
augmented lagrangian compared to admm
um
and then ADM where you don't solve all
uh till the variants actually we never
do this right you have an inexact ADN M
and that's what most people are using
however in ADM the Y is always fixed in
the first problem to optimize over X or
to find the next here we don't need this
here it is adapted because we are on a
different manifold and this I just
illustrate by using for example a linear
a different regularization uh different
step size different learning rate over
here which is not just the linearized
one if I choose that I go to the con
convergence much faster over here in
just 40 iteration or 30 iteration
compare to 120 why the step length so is
significantly different so methods are
really different there you are operating
on different manifests
um because there are so many
applications I want to just show you
some I played around with which are just
fun uh to do and this one is for example
uh Trend a graph Trend filtering where
with missing data so you have uh here
for example the roadmap uh map of
Minnesota and you have some Trend in the
data and there are some missing black
dots and you want to re reconstruct this
information of the two data and you can
do that via L1 regularization here the
operator looks a little bit different
than just the standard finite difference
one but it is a fun fun to play with
these kind of problems and they they are
solved very fast
here's another problem which I mentioned
already in the beginning so which is
super resolution you have a bunch of
small resolution images and now I put a
Tony on the spot what do you think about
the is this can you identify what the
image is
an astronaut yeah exactly that's an
astronaut and if you actually do this
pixel information and you do the
Reconstruction this is the true one and
this is their reconstruction I'm getting
uh with the pal over here I don't know
if I have another example or I have one
more but that is already in my
conclusion I think I finished up
hopefully about in time so uh my first
uh please
variable rejection is underutilized and
uh it is fun to play with that and can
give surprisingly good results in many
different ways we used it also and and
training neural networks separable and
neural networks which I didn't talk
about today but if you are looking at
some sparse recovery with some lasso
problems people have some fast
conversions
of course this is just the beginning of
uh things we are investigating one thing
is I so far I talked about non-year
linear operators of our writers we don't
need to change our code our code works
for non-linear operators as well that we
haven't played with that as well so if
there are some non-linear pdes involved
in that that would be very interesting
we just last week tried to do and
dictionary learning here you see the
first results actually I have already
better results so we ran it already
twice and did some dictionary learning
but more to come in the future I didn't
talk about much about changing the Norms
you can do this with this separable
function as well if you are separating
um or the splitting of the variables you
you can leverage there are some points
as well
um my collaborator works on joint
inversion at the moment if you have two
different modalities and you want to
join this information for example in
software surface Imaging we are doing
that right now and looking at some
results over there I talked very briefly
about convergence but there's still a
lot more to do and where I want to go
and I spent some time on randomized
methods I want to include them in this
framework as well so that we can go to
larger Dimensions even than we are doing
right now
I talked a bit about the selection of
the regularization parameter but there
is still lots to do it depends a little
bit still on the operator how can we get
information out of that that's also
something we are currently working on
and I just showed you this simple
version of a vital with a certain uh
descent Direction and step size
selection but we can generalize this and
we can use different things we already
started that as well and it works fine
but there are still a long way to go and
with this uh I'm happy to take any
questions thank you everyone
yeah thank you very much Atia for the
wonderful talk I believe everyone
enjoyed TS talk as much as I do so now
is the Q a section so please feel free
to amuse yourself and ask questions
uh yeah maybe I can start um by asking a
question so I um I'm curious about
um the neural network approach for
getting the um the regularization
parameter so I can see that getting the
parameter in the online phase is shape
but in the offline phase you have to
solve for the optimal parameter so how
expensive is that labeling process
actually
you hit the nail on the head you know
that that is the expense who convinces
part at the moment over here
um uh the new training the neural
network is a piece of cake really that
that is the easy part but finding the
optimal parameters uh yeah not
necessarily even convex problem
and uh we we went uh already in some
directions that uh is reinforcement
learning that we are learning it on the
Fly what a good parameter is not the
optimal but ignoring what the optimal is
but trying to reconstruct the image of
the optimal parameter so trying to
ignore that one however so far that is
also computational expensive and
reinforcement learning is not really
prone to converge very fast so that is
something we are working on right now
but uh good question very good question
I see yeah thanks for the answer so uh
so
is there a question from the audience
yep
[Music]
um
yeah I uh thanks for great talk uh on
PhD from GST Austin so I just following
um
uh questions I I just follow that and uh
I think there is a paper that people the
rich the the author they they train the
trainable parameters in the uh inverse
problem framework they they train the
the regularizer and uh
regularization parameter at the same
time
and they achieved a better than the
normal techno regularizations I mean in
that work is like
not only trained the optimal
regularization parameter but they also
train
um I think the inverse map at the same
time so yeah I I just mentioned that so
you can look on that and make
configuration you're talking about 10
boo intense work on that uh no uh no
okay okay so there is some work on uh
there as well and what we try to avoid
over here is uh learning the inverse map
from from B to X then that is the
inverse problem and I know that there's
a tons of work out there and it's very
interesting but we wanted to keep the
physical model really in place we didn't
want to touch this piece but you're
right there there's a lot of interesting
workout nevertheless uh whatever paper
you have there in mind please uh send it
to me I'm very interested about
developments which are the issue yeah
because what I have in mind is you know
like um instead of we just waste a
resource to train only the
regularization parameter right uh
learning like the the approach learning
regularizer they also have the same
meaning they include Optimum
uh regularization parameter with
the prior like the the like the the
proper regularizer for the invest
problem so which like we we have the
like one
um one key two birds something like that
instead of uh only regularization
yeah yeah so uh to be honest we we uh
that's why I did it a bold phase so we
learned a diff not only one
regularization parameter we did multiple
different things one thing is for
example what we learned which was was
interesting
uh how many
um internet solves I should do in my
inversion process because that is for
example implicit regularization right so
that I have my B and I will get how many
iterations should I when should I start
with my iterations right other things is
for example you might want to have
a mean or some covariance information
right so you want a parameters
covariance also you want to maybe learn
that one yeah this is these are all
different options which which is really
great and we haven't explored everything
yet but I'm really very curious please
send me the paper or the link to the
paper yeah thank you yep and yeah I just
like uh one one more not like you
mentioned about Big Data uh invest
problem right and then if we have big
data and we need to do
uh fighter Optimum for training data I
think is a very expensive file yeah so
um there's some work we did on iterative
uh so it's on sketching Etc sketching if
you have your large and you just use
pieces of your data and there's
relationship is between the sampled
regularization parameters the Sam the
the regularization to the sample problem
to the overall regularization parameter
and if you're doing internet selling you
can actually
learn the regularization why you are
going which is very interesting and we
applied this uh for for linear problems
this is called slim tick sample limited
memory tick enough or then for neural
networks this is called sample limited
memory training so slim training
oh you do you have a network on the
Yahoo scholar
yeah it should be it's called if you
look slim train then you will find it I
hope so okay thank you great sure yeah
thank you so much
okay so we got some fruits for a
discussion so um are there any more
questions from the audience
so
um if we hide here
uh this is uh this is England I'm
currently a postdoc at Purdue University
and thanks for your wonderful talk my
question is related to uh can you maybe
turn to page 23rd or somewhere or you
have a figure showing the uh how the
accuracy will change with respect to the
choice of regularization
uh this one yeah yes yeah yeah this
figure on the left top or laptop and I'm
wondering that for the data driven case
we actually have the noise model right
so we have some principles that we can
actually choose a relative okay
parameter meal right so maybe not an
optimal for each measurement but it's an
okay one so my question is that will the
Reconstruction be quite sensitive to the
choice of the meal when it is near this
relative good regularization parameter
that is an extremely good question right
and uh first of all I want to answer it
it always depends on the application
right so how sensitive your
regularization parameter is right
we we see here for example their
regularization program will be 10 to the
minus 4 and 10 to the minus two it will
give give me the uh pretty much the same
result right and but uh
um if we have a good method to just a
priori estimated plug it in right that
that will definitely help if I'm looking
though at the discrepancy principle or
um
for large scale problems they're
extremely expensive because you need to
invert this system multiple times
right so uh and that becomes very
expensive and that's why we are
currently working on uh using the dnn's
particular for this problem but also
including information about the operator
so that uh not only B but also the
operator just some small information is
in there that we can have a quick
information about the
uh uh
the regularization parameter and you're
right maybe additional information maybe
noise variants if I know that I should
plug it in right I can get out uh
there's something out and I would love
to include that yeah
thank you thank you for your answer
I I uh yeah I just like
um have a following uh comment on on
this one as well uh there is a active
Subspace methods for inverse problems so
uh actually I did reach out on that and
if we apply a types of space
or inverse problem here so we will uh or
latch uh like over regularization
parameter we we we will
still get a good result like the other
space will robots nuts with the overall
regularizations uh parameter so you will
not have the inaccurate uh go blows up
on with the large regularization
parameter
maybe I don't follow uh follow are you
saying you you want an iterative
approach to just use the
um large singular values essentially to
reconstruct or do you want to
yeah yeah cut up like that yes yeah that
that would have been uh method in there
but that is typically more for L2
regularization well one it becomes a
little bit more difficult right
yes I I agree yeah thank you
okay so if there are no more questions
let's fight against here for his um
wonderful talk and sharing his excellent
results of us
okay
um
recording here